hello everyone um so as i mentioned
today my talk will be about large-scale
field delineation
before i start
let me introduce myself my name as
mentioned again israel jose can i'm a
machine learning scientist and
intelligent there and besides that i'm a
physics master's student at yerma state
university faculty of physics
my specific
areas
of work are computer vision for machine
learning and high energy physics
elementary particle physics
etc my hobbies
even though you don't probably don't
care are sports and gaming
so let's just jump right into
uh the main topic
so first of all what is field
delineation so field delineation is
basically just the estimation of field
boundaries
this can be done
in a number of different ways either by
hand or by
automated machines
and it's really a very broad definition
it's just the estimation of boundaries
so why do we need it
well given that modern agriculture is
still field based
so everything is on the field level
usually usually farmers don't
collaborate as much even if they do
everything is specific to the fields
if we want to use some tasks to
help
farmers we need to be able to delineate
the fields and have each specific field
so someone might wonder who cares about
agriculture well
good question
but given the environmental and
the geopolitical
chaos in the world right now
aggregate the full global food shortages
are becoming now more
scary than in the past i don't know how
many years so investing in agriculture
is key to solving some potential issues
that might come back to bite us in the
future
and what does ai have to do with
agriculture well ai has infiltrated
basically everything at this point
so given the rise of machine learning ai
again has been become integral for the
development of agriculture so
aerial imagery is used by companies like
us to maximize
yield potential crop health and assist
farmers and basically having better
farms
so now that these are out of the way
what is our solution field delineation
like as i said you can do an automated
pipeline that's what we use we use an
encoder decoder based
deep neural network network to predict
the delineated fields using aerial
imager
so
i'll go step by step um
over our workflow which is firstly
creating the data then creating the
model post-processing the model
predictions and going to a larger scale
but as of now
that's this is just the gist of it we
want to use the deep neural network okay
so if we want to use machine learning
and neural networks we need data
so
section one
data collection
what data do we need well we want to
predict field boundaries field extents
so obviously we need
the masked annotated
fields of areas
this is the picture on the right so this
is the annotated mask of the fields in a
given area
now besides that we obviously since we
wanted to train with aerial imagery need
some aerial imagery of large scale
lands
so
basically field heavy areas something
like this
so all we need essentially is images of
some areas that have a lot of fields
like this one and some annotations of
those areas to be able to change the
model so
input and ground truth
so where do we get these this data from
let's start from i guess the harder part
the field data
so for the field masks obviously
like
no one
none of you i think have that good idea
where to get annotated masks of fields
so
this is the harder part and we have
chosen three sources here the first one
is
the french government's
yearly release of their field data i'm
not going to try to pronounce this
because i'm going to butcher it horribly
but it's basically the french
government's yearly release of all
fields of and france
um
it's so this image was
from the rpg data
and
it's a really good data set it's dense
it's clean it's accurate the only
downside it's french now no offense to
french people
but
our interests lie in the american domain
because our customers in america
are in america so using french data
there's a bit of a domain shift um
having french data
kind of hinders that
but it's a very good data set regardless
in most applications of field
delineation this is the go to data
so
okay we want american data
americans have american government has
their data too this is called the common
land unit data or clu for short
the data set is very dense
the data is american freedom um and
so
it's good in dances but the downside is
that it's an old data set because it's
been privatized by the government since
2008 so the best data you're going to
have is from 2008 and obviously a lot
has changed since then and the data has
a lot of false positives which isn't
necessarily an issue with the data set
it's how we use it because common land
unit
um
i'm guessing some of you wonder what
that is it's
basically the
definition
of something like a farm but that
definition also includes stuff like
lakes and forests so those are also
annotated and
thus if we use this data we have a lot
of uh false positives so all now we have
this data it's an american data set but
it's not particularly
um
it's not of good quality
and then
third perk of being from intel in there
we have data annotated by our annotators
so this data is extremely clean it's
fresh and it's accurate so it's
basically perfect wherever we have it
but the thing is it's only data of our
customers fields and thus it's sparse
and it's smaller so having a large scale
training only on it is practically
impossible
and what have we chosen well we've
chosen two data sources actually and
i'll get into how we use the two
together in a bit but we've chosen the
french rpg data and the intel and their
data
so i'll when i say our data or intel on
their data i'm gonna mean this and when
i say rpg data i'm going to need this
different experiments have been done
this this
choice of data sources is the one that
yielded the best results and here i
brought some examples of the two data
sets so given an rgb image this is the
french rpg data you can see what i meant
it's really clean it's really accurate
and it's very dense
um
and this is our data it's again
clean and accurate but it's very sparse
as you can see and that's just
fundamentally how the data is
um
so now that we've got the data source
sources uh checked out
let's talk about the aerial imagery we
mentioned that we want to train on
aerial imagery and we basically given
what data sources we chose for the masks
we have to choose some aerial
imagery source that basically covers the
entirety of the united states and the
entirety of
the french republic that's a huge area
this basically means
um imagery that cover the entire world
here we have had two choices one is
sentinel-2 imagery sentinel 2 as a
satellite
that gives free imagery
on a 10 meter resolution 10 to 60 we use
10 meter resolution um basically
anywhere
so
this is the first trade and the second
is map box which is
not a free provider but another perk of
working at intel there we have a map box
subscription so um i was we were able to
use mapbox
api to get their imageries now mapbox
resolution they differ from all the way
up to
tens of thousands of kilometers to even
a couple centimeters per pixel even
lower than that so
map box imageries are like as you can
see a bit cleaner we have more freedom
so given that we have access to it we've
chosen to go forward with mapbox data
and now that we have the data sources
figured out let's move on to the model
creation so we want to train a model as
mentioned we need an input and we need a
target
so as the input we have chosen the rgb
image as i said this is what mapbox
provides and that's the target mask we
have chosen
three masks to predict so first one is a
boundary mask where
one denotes the boundary of a field
and zero denotes
not the boundary of the field
the extent mask which is basically the
field
one the notes field and zero the notes
not a field
as you can see here these are the fields
and then the third one is the distance
mask so what is the distance mask i
guess you can figure it out already it's
basically how far a pixel is from the
banner pixels that are furthest from the
boundary they have the higher values so
this is for instance in the middle it's
one and near the edges it's closer to
zero
so
and one of our sources that we've uh
used this is proven to be a beneficial
choice of target masks we have tried
some experiments without using the
distance mask
while it may seem counterintuitive like
why would you use it it actually
improves
results
in general
so
now let's talk about the thing that i
mentioned
before so domain shift we have french
data but we want to train and we want to
do inferences on american fields how do
we train a model using this so in our
in the source paper by franz walder and
sharon wang
they discussed this
issue while trying to train on french
data for
in and predict on indian fields so they
have the same issue just different
countries
the french data is available for
everyone indian data is not and as you
can see here there is a disparity
between field sizes and brands and field
sizes in india so
whatever way you go there is going to be
the main shift if you just try to train
on french data and predict on america
how do they
tackle this problem they use
transfer learning and weekly supervised
learning so what is weekly supervised
learning let's talk about that for a bit
so basically the thing is
um since there isn't
a lot of data in india
they have to annotate it by themselves
now data annotation costs money takes
time
so you have to if you have limited
resources you can't
i don't know
mask all of india you have to make a
choice
do i um
annotate a lot of images
that are sparsely annotated like this
one so we have this image only a few
fields have been masked and annotated or
do i have a few samples and annotate it
densely so something like this
if you have limited resources that's the
choice you have so in their paper they
say that using an approach like this
where you annotate a few fields and mask
everything out
it's better than having a few examples
of densely annotated data
so in their case
they did this because of limited
resources but remembering what our data
looks like
this kind of looks like our problem
we come from a different
point but we arrive at the same problem
and they prove that using this approach
is beneficial actually not even it's
okay it's beneficial to use this
and
the
they also use transfer learning so
basically this is the approach they use
um
they train on monthly planet mosaics
feed that input to a neural network and
that in their case they use a fractal
resunet
they trained that one on
a french government collected boundaries
so the rpg data
then they use some other imageries for
india this doesn't particularly matter
for our case because we just use mapbox
in any case
and they
transfer the weights of the french model
to the indian model and then they train
on these masked
inputs on the indian data
so they
train on densely annotated french data
they transfer the weights to
a different model and
fine-tune that model basically using
weekly supervised learning with masked
indeed
data so that's the approach they use
um a different problem that uh
i mentioned and that they've tackled is
the difference between field sizes like
as i mentioned you can see here it's
about six times uh
french fields are about six times larger
than indium fields
and so that's going to give a difference
um on your imagery what they do is they
downsample french imagery
uh so the average pixel sizes of the
fields are the same for indian and
french data
obviously this works if you down sample
you go higher the obviously the real
size of the fails doesn't change but the
pixel sizes on each image pixel areas
they
get smaller and using this technique you
can see the difference here has closed
up
the french and indian
[Music]
field sizes are basically the same
size on average
pixel wise so that this is another thing
that they use down or up sampling in our
case since american fields are larger
the initial data to have the same pixel
size improves results
so let's circle back to our data this
everything was just a citation
now let's come to our data our data is
also sparse as i mentioned so this
weekly supervised stuff seems to be
suited specifically for us but there's
one very key difference
here as you can see if you look closely
they have
field interior
not enfield and masked out
so they have negatively annotated
parts
even though it's mostly masked out the
parts that are are annotated sorry
have some negative annotations in our
case we only have the fields of our
customers so fundamentally we don't have
any negative annotations if we take the
annotations that we do have and mask out
the rest we're basically going to have
100 positively annotated data so this is
a key point and this is a problem
but regardless we're going to try this
approach and we're going to try to
mitigate this later
and for this field alignment i've called
this so the field size
symmetry stuff that they
try to get the same pixel size we've
done this as well
american fields are larger on average
than french fields and thus we have
trained the french data set on a mix of
zoom levels map boxes zoom level 13 and
zoom level 14 resolutions so mapbox as i
said they have a number of different
resolutions they're just numbered um the
resolution we want
their calls on level 13 and 14 and here
are the resolutions so it's about the
first one is one point
six meters and the other one is point
eight meters
um
now that we have all this sorted out
this is our final um pipeline basically
of training
and here we tackle the problem of having
no negative annotations what we do is
um during the
end of the training scheme we do a very
small training on the french data again
so basically fine tuning very small i
can't stress this enough like one or two
epochs
this is just for a model to see some
negative annotations and uh be able to
predict some stuff like forests and
lakes as negative if not for this the
model performs very well at delineating
everything but it treats everything as a
field so it will be very good at um
segmenting a lake from a field but it's
going to say they're both different
fields
so
going over everything we use the french
zoom 13 and zoom 14 data we train
a model using both of them
and get this french
zoom 13 and a half let's call it model
transfer the weights like they did
in their paper and
um
on we fine tune using our so
intelliner's zoom 13 model data we get
this model that is very good at
delineating everything but predicts
positive everything
and then we do a very small fine tuning
using zoom 14 french data anything could
go here 13 could go both could go we
just do a fine tuning using zoom 14
french data and we get our final model
so this is the training scheme that we
have chosen um the paper suggests this
much
so without this fine tuning but given
our problem this was something we have
to add
and these are the final model
performances so the metrics here
the mandatory metrics might be low
like if you just look at it without
context but that's just fundamentally
how it's supposed to be you can imagine
if you have a boundary mask and another
boundary mask if you try to calculate
the metrics and i don't know the
predicted boundary mask is shift by
shifted by a single pixel
like boundaries look at what they are
if everything is
shifted by a single pixel there's not
going to be any overlaps so the metrics
are going to be low
and that's just a fundamental
property of boundary data and as such
these might seem low but they're
actually pretty pretty good results and
you can look at the field
metrics which are pretty high uh the
these are the results of the final
models of this one after all this
training
now we have a model um that is
able to predict fields and boundaries
great
so
before moving on let me stress a key
point
under-segmenting is worse than
over-segmenting
why is that if you have to a field
let's say a single field if you
predicted um
as two separate fields
it's easier for a person to just combine
them but if you have two fields
and the model predicts them as a single
field it's very hard to
so you basically have to do whatever it
is you're trying to solve using machine
learning you have to go and delineate it
again so you haven't solved anything so
in this task over segmenting so
splitting the field into a couple
smaller fields is better than under
segmenting so that's a key point that we
want to remember going forward now
our model is very good as you can see at
detecting field and boundaries but it's
very bad at closing boundaries so if you
want to get
a field instances from this
you you'll see that some fields are
going to connect by a single pixel like
here it didn't close and this is a
single field
um
so
this is a problem
but
there are specific techniques that are
used to
tackle this and the technique used is
called watershed segmentation
watershed segmentation is a pretty
common technique in instant segmentation
you can see
on the bottom this technique is used to
like with 100 accuracy basically um
they segment
these coins from each other
and this very common technique what is
it
now
any grayscale image you can treat it as
a topological image so
you can
view it as a map where higher values are
like mountains and lower valleys are
like valleys
so if you have a probability map where
you have enough values from zero to one
you can imagine that as a top
topographical map now the
basis of watershed segmentation is
let's treat this map
um like an actual map let's
take the local minima minimi and let's
start filling them with water water so
the water levels will rise as you can
see from here
it will rise it'll rise from here then
on this so on this line the two will
start to spill into each other
the point is as soon as two
neighboring
valleys they start pouring into each
other you put a boundary there
and you repeat this process over the
entire image
so basically you take each local
minimize so basically something like a
point in this field
and then point it in this field you
start filling it with water as soon as
the waters touch you put a boundary
there and then you go on doing that for
the entire field and after that
you just take everything like this is
the first label this is the second label
this is a third label so you're able to
segment the instances from
each other using this method
and
here are the results
you can see how big a difference it
makes so it's very good at
like delineating and closing the
boundaries and just having
different instances for each field
um so the watershed segmentation helps a
ton but besides that we have a couple
smaller uh stuff we do uh while cross
processing first one is the watershed
segmentation that's like a key thing
without that our model would not be as
good as it is um then we do something
like um small field cleanups so if you
look here i don't know if it's
noticeable uh on the presentation but um
there are some like random red dots here
um i don't know if you can see it but
like it's a model it's gonna predict um
some random dots as fields or boundaries
in the middle of nowhere
um
that aren't actually useful for us so
what we do is um we just set a threshold
and we discard all the fields that are
smaller than a certain value
this is just a step for us to actually
clean the data up and finally after this
we throw away the boundary mask that we
have predicted and we use the boundaries
of the field mask
so
um like the predicted boundary mask you
can see here and i think this one is
with the
boundaries and the field map so you just
take each instance take its boundary and
that's your boundary mask now
this also
makes the results a bit cleaner
even though at this point the boundary
mask has lost most of its use so it's
not particularly important
okay so now we have a model that is good
at predicting um the
fields and the boundaries of a single
tile okay that's great but how do we
move to a larger scale
like
usually you do these segmentation tasks
moving up to a higher scale isn't that
hard because you can just combine
everything
but here we have a specific problem
since we're doing instant segmentation
rather than just segmentation
look at these two tiles they're tiles
next to each other so on the left one is
to the west one is to the east and
there's plenty too and look
fields that got get caught in the middle
of these two tiles so this field in this
field
they also get split in two
so if you just do a tile by tile
approach like take an area
iterate over all the tiles and do
predictions
some fields like this one are gonna
split in two okay
one might wonder let's just
[Music]
let's just combine everything that
touches each other okay a good point but
there's this little strip of land that
isn't part of this field but it's gonna
connect because
like
farms don't have to be rectangular
um
they can be in all sorts of shapes and
sizes and some fields can touch
even though they're different fields and
if we're unlucky that this can be
directly on this boundary line and
besides that
our model might not predict all the way
up to the boundary because it's a model
it might just have a one pixel wide
gap between the two instances so just
combining doesn't work
so we have a problem
that we want to solve from going to a
smaller scale to a larger scale and this
is the
solution that we've
made up
so
um
bear with me
so what we do is for each tile in the
grid so we take an area and we iterate
over all the tiles now for every
specific tile we do an inference on the
tile
and after doing the interference we get
something like this
then we discard all the geometries
that touch the boundary so basically we
discard this one this one this one
everything that touches the boundary of
the tile we discard it
so right now we have the
prediction of fields that are 100 in the
tile these are not split these are
correct
um
but we want to predict the tile fields
on the boundaries as well to do that we
create a larger tile you um
using the tile on the right and the tile
on the bottom so imagine this is a
single tile so this quarter we create
this larger tile
concatenating basically the tile to the
right and the tile to the bottom making
it a two by two tile
so to see
so we have this larger tile that
basically includes all the fields on the
right and the lower
boundaries
after that we do imprints on this larger
tile
so now we have
all the fields in a larger area so
if we went by 512 and 512 we have all
the fields of of a 10 24 by 10 24 tile
and then we discard all geometries that
do not touch
this south
east boundary of the original tile
so
you by basically we discard all the
geometries that don't touch from the
directions that we
made the tile larger
by doing this we basically have the
field
uh fields
internal geometries from here
sorry
from here
and we have the geometries of its
southern and eastern border from here
now we concatenate these and we have the
geometries of the tile
the internal geometries of the tile and
its southern border and its eden eastern
border
besides this we
remove some intersecting geometries
because obviously we do predictions on
the same area twice there might be some
intersections of fields that don't quite
touch the boundary now we remove these
even though those are less of a problem
and right now for each tile we have
all the geometries
except
the ones on its
northern and western boundaries
how do we tackle this we don't
for each tile except on the first column
and the first row
their northern boundary is going to be a
southern boundary of another tile
so it's going to be accounted for using
the method that we used so
in reality we're going to have a single
row and a single column that don't have
a
prediction don't have proper predictions
for one of their boundaries so what we
just if we have a specific area we want
to do the imprints on we do it on a
larger area and just ignore the first
row we call
so yeah after that
those are the final geometries
of an area so
using this method
no matter how large you have uh your
area you can do your inference on
your only limitation is basically your
ram but
you can upload the geometry to a
database at any point you can write them
to
your machine so this basically takes
some time
but it's scalable you can go
to any scale without any limitations and
here you can see
this basically is almost as big as
illinois itself it's
illinois a bit of indiana some kentucky
and missouri so
the influence has been done on this very
large patch of land
um using this method and
like this is scalable to an even larger
extent if you wanted if you had enough
time you could do this over the entire
united states
um
so
uh
to conclude
um we used publicly available french
data and our annotated data along with
map box imagery for training
we used transfer learning and this
method called weekly supervised learning
to effectively use
both our data sources
um and we used watershed segmentation to
post-process our predictions because
otherwise the instances were incorrect
we created this technique
to be able to move to a larger scale
and we used all this to do the
predictions on the following area
um so these are the sources um
that we used as i said this one
is the one with
where they suggest
watershed segmentation weekly supervised
learning transfer learning
and this is a medium article actually
that um
basically was a good
baseline for us to start our
research
thank you do you have any questions
thank you very interesting talk uh i
have actually two questions
uh how does the seasonality affect all
of this work is there a preferred season
or do you have to do this maybe multiple
times a year
um that's something we have
discussed um it's something that
like
depends on the season obviously because
the imagerys it might be easier
to tell a forest apart from
grasslands
or a field depending on its color but
we've used mapbox which is actually i
think an aggregation of different season
times so the imageries are not from a
single point they're this
different complex mashup of different
time stamps so um
the seasonality is something that is
definitely a point but we haven't
tackled specifically in this
uh research the predictions were done
during
it doesn't matter so it was done using
map box imagery which is yeah um
different just combined
and the second question is actually
about the slide when you stitch together
these two tiles
is there an overlap or a little bit area
that's missing oh the mapbox just
perfectly goes tight
the way they use the
you just give a tile number and their
api gives back a tile and they perfectly
follow each other so there's no
overlapping
exactly the same as it can just stitch
them together make sense thanks
thank you for the speech
i actually have two questions one is
really small is the rpg data set open
source yes okay and the second question
is you said that you can even take the
whole image of united states and
feed it to your model and it will work
but isn't there an issue with the
boundaries getting smaller and the
fields getting
smaller and you cannot differentiate
between
uh so you mean going to a higher
resolution yeah like there is an upper
bound where you can i actually meant
like um going same resolution but just a
larger area so you're gonna have the
fields of the same size just go all the
way over the united states okay that's
gonna take ages i was just
saying there's specifically no upper
limit you can do anything you want but
yeah realistically predicting over the
entire united states using this method
yeah
and also do you use like a custom model
or it's just like a unit based um we use
um so here in the paper they suggest
using a um fractal resunet
um it's their model for um i think
specifically for stuff like this
in our research we've used
resunet 34 so
a res a resident sorry a unit where a
resnet 34 backbone uh so yeah any model
really works uh we have we did add
dilation because
the inputs are like so um finicky so
having dilation helps but yeah in
essence the model isn't critical any
model uh having a unit based
architecture will suffice
thank you
yeah thank you for the presentation and
it's great work
uh
one question i wanted to understand so
you you did this
uh
unusual trick of fine tuning
on
not the final data set at the end right
that's yep that's a pretty rare thing i
think and
did you try to
uh measure whether you lose anything
like if you if you do that you you had
multiple metrics right precision recall
so
uh
maybe i missed this part so if these are
these are fields or these are like
pixels
um they're they're the pixel level um
metrics for the field mask okay for
mass okay so did you notice any like
uh
before you did this final fine tuning oh
wow you had
false positives right that was your
problem the thing is uh we had more
false negatives so like here
um
sorry
we have a lot of false negatives we
barely have any false positives and the
metrics indeed were very high but they
weren't
telling us anything because they were
only calculated on positive samples so
it was like
unusually high that didn't tell us
anything because of how the data was
constructed so there is no way of
knowing
whether or not
the french fine tune actually damaged
basically the positive
um
predictions
of our model but it definitely improves
the negative ones
so you were not able to measure how
if it damaged or not is that what you
say um we have not measured whether or
not this final trick has damaged the
prediction of the field specifically
uh in general as i said it improves but
for the fields um i understand what
you're asking it's we haven't measured
it yeah i think
one another option that you could try i
don't know if you did
you could simply add like 10
of this french data to your data set
and
yeah that would i think uh
have the same
effect since this fine tuning was so
small i think what you mentioned
it could work yeah that's something we
could have tried definitely interesting
yeah it's an interesting thing to do
like i wouldn't risk that but
obviously yeah if you if you do it's
like slow enough and with small learning
rate and yeah maybe you don't do the
forgetting yeah thank you it's very
interesting
sorry maybe i missed this part but do
you actually use the images as your
input and output or do you use some kind
of representation oh sorry can you
repeat do you
do you take the images as your input and
output or do you some kind of
representation of the image um we use
just the rbg
rgb image as the input and you use these
three masks as target masks so
it's just the image because some of like
those images are can have some like
simple representation in certain bases
or something that could help you because
like the regions are you know locally
they are very constant or the boundaries
are just unions of curves
um
it could we haven't tried anything like
that it's just these
as the inputs
thank you
did you try adding any other features
for example annual precipitation
or time of year at which the imagery was
taken for distance from urban center
uh no
these are just the stuff we've tried the
time of season was something that we've
discussed so it was something that we
have considered but at the end we ended
up not using it
so this is all we've used and the other
stuff we haven't tried at all
i'm sure you do use some data
augmentation but have you tried using
like some
like copy paste type of augmentations
where you take your sparse
annotations and put it on some
background where there are no fields
like
have you tried those type of um
the thing is for our uh small data set
our model would usually go in the wrong
direction because of these that are
annotated as negative
um
yeah but i mean you like uh copy those
masked areas where you know they're
definitely fields and you paste it on a
completely different image where there
are no fields um no we haven't tried it
but it's an interesting thought so it
basically the um
where the stuff is right so where like
you can just uh paste it on a lake let's
say yeah yeah it's definitely
interesting we haven't tried it
it hasn't crossed my mind that something
like that that could be done something
we know for a fact that is negative but
it's definitely interesting stuff
thank you thank you